آه ،
إذا ذهب أحدهم إلى الأردن ولم يزور
البتراء ، فربما تكون قد بقيت في
المنزل أيضًا ،
لقد كنت هنا من قبل
ودائمًا ما كان مليئًا
بالناس والحمير والضوضاء والروائح ،
هذا علاج رائع ،
هناك طريقة واحدة فقط للدخول و  طريقة واحدة للخروج
من المدينة القديمة ومن
خلال المرضى تجربة خاصة بها
تذكر كل هؤلاء الملوك والإمبراطوريات الذين
أداروا هذا المكان
هنا ، كان النبطيون قبل 2000
عام هم الذين أنشأوا عاصمة إمبراطورية
من
الصخور ، السيخ هو في الواقع  نتاج
حدث طبيعي ، حدث زلزال
منذ ملايين السنين أدى إلى تشتيت الصخور ،
وإذا نظرت إلى التكوين ، فستدرك
أنه إذا كان سيتم دفعه معًا ، فسيكون
مناسبًا تمامًا مرة
أخرى ، وكان النبطيون تجارًا بارعين وعلماء هيدرولوجيين بارعين
كانوا يعرفون أنهم بحاجة  الماء إذا كان لهذا
المكان أن ينجح حقًا إذا كان
عليهم البقاء على قيد الحياة ،
لذا فقد تكيفوا ونحتوا وخلقوا
قنوات مائية في هذه الصخرة ،
يمكنك الحصول على لمحة عنها
، ثم ترى المزيد
يا إلهي في كل مرة
إنه أمر
لا يُصدق
وهناك خزينة البتراء ،
خذها في
التنفس
[موسيقى]
كان النبطيون
تجارًا ورجال الأعمال
المتميزين ، وكما يمكنك أن تتخيل عندما
تصل إلى هنا اليوم ،
فإن نجاحاتهم
تنتظرك بالفعل
[موسيقى]
موقع رائع  الموقع هذا هو
ما يعنيه
أن تكون مثيرًا للإعجاب للغاية وقد
صرحوا بذلك بقولهم أن هذا هو من
نحن ،
هذا هو مكتب الأستاذ سامي الحسينات
حيث نشأ ومهمته
الآن تجعل الزائرين مثلي
يفهمون العمق.  أهمية
موقع التراث العالمي لليونسكو هذا
كل يوم أراه بشكل مختلف
كل يوم
لأنه
بالنسبة لي يبدو أنه التركيز على
صورة كلما زاد تركيزك كلما
رأيت أكثر كلما اكتشفت أن
البتراء مثيرة للإعجاب بالتأكيد
ولكن سيدي المرشدون الأفضل
في كل مكان
أدركت أخيرًا أن ما
يلفت انتباهي
هو عيونهم والخط الأسود من حولهم
ما الذي تضعه على عينيك
لماذا فقط تنظف  إن العيون تكسر العيون
من الرمال ، والشمس مختلفة
حقًا ، نعم بالطبع ، لذا فهي ليست
مستحضرات تجميل
من الشمس
نعم
أجلس هنا
،
هل تنفجر لا لا لا لا لا
أقصد ولكن يمكنني مسحها ،
نعم
لا تقلق
ما لا تقلق أنت تعرفه ، لقد
اشتريت عيني
آخر الكلمات الشهيرة
ما يمكن أن يحدث خطأ قريب
يا إلهي افتح جاهزًا افتح عينيك يا
بترا بالطبع أكثر من
الخزانة اصعد الطريق وينتهي بك الأمر
وسط المدينة
كان هذا هو القلب النابض للبتراء ،
لذا كان عدد الأشخاص هنا
حوالي 40 ألف شخص خلال
أبرز أحداث البتراء بين القرن الأول
قبل الميلاد والقرن الأول ، حيث
كانت هناك مدينة مزدحمة للغاية
لأنهم شاركوا في التجارة مع
التجارة
كانوا الأغنى في العالم بأسره
في ذلك الوقت بسبب طرق التجارة
التي أصبحوا تجارًا قدموا
خدماتهم
وتلقوا الرسوم والضرائب
على الأغنياء والنبلاء على
رأس الفقراء وكل شخص آخر أسفل
مكان لطيف مع  منظر
يمكنك إلقاء نظرة
عليه لأكثر من ألف عام ، تم
التخلي عن البتراء ، ثم بدأ الأوروبيون في
الحفر كما كانوا يريدون القيام به في عام 1812
ويستمر هذا الاستكشاف تحت العديد من القبعات
حتى اليوم
يقول الأستاذ الحسينات إن ما نراه
هو جزء بسيط من  ما تبقى
لتكتشفه ، أغمض عينيك ، لا تفتحهما ،
سآخذك بأمان
إلى الحافة ، لا تقلق ، يمكنك فتح
عينيك الآن ،
واو واو
مفاجأة المدرج
يتكيف مع 4000 متفرج
[موسيقى]
عندما أتيت إلى خراب قديم مثل
هذا ،
كنت أتوق دائمًا إلى أن يتم نقلي إلى
الوراء للحظة فقط
لأرى ما كان عليه في الواقع مثل
الضوضاء ، تنبعث رائحة الأوساخ ، أوه
فقط
للحظة صغيرة ،
أعدني إلى هناك ،
هذه الصخور محفورة  بدليل حضارات
البتراء القديمة وما تمثله محفور
في الحمض النووي للأردن اليوم